okay so I wanted to talk about violence
in video games because I've got to pro
gamers with me I've confirmed that
independently these are big video game
people you guys may remember that I was
assistant manager at Electronics
Boutique in Hicksville Long Island in
the late 90s so I know a little bit
about topic myself moved more Pokemon
than anyone know that's that's what I
tell people the American Psychological
Association on their website list some
myths versus facts about video game
violence and I'm not quite sure I agree
with them myth number one violent video
game research has yielded very mixed
results facts this is according to them
some studies have yielded non
significant video game effects just as
some smoking studies failed to find a
significant link to lung cancer violent
video games are significantly associated
with increased aggressive behavior
thoughts and affect increased
physiological arousal and decreased
pro-social helping behavior okay I got
some problems with that but let's get
through all of them myth number two
there are no studies linking violent
video game play to serious aggression
fact high levels of violent video game
exposure have been linked to delinquency
fighting at school and during free play
periods and violent criminal behavior I
mean what else you gonna do they're in
free play periods and number three
unrealistic video game violence is
completely safe for adolescents and
older youths facts cartoonish and
fantasy violence is often perceived
incorrectly by parents and public
policymakers as safe however
experimental studies with college
students have consistently found
increased aggression after exposure to
clearly unrealistic and fantasy violent
video games okay so they're giving us a
lot to work with there so you know what
I'm just gonna let you talk before I ask
a question thanks Dave
yeah well I've covered this a lot on my
channel it's one of my most went I don't
want to say pet because I hate it a lot
yeah there were a few problems I had in
those myths versus facts first of all it
says aggressive behavior aggressive
isn't necessarily violent like kilee
with a gun yeah first of all another one
was there was
linked to delinquency a link to this
kind of person but that doesn't really
correlation is not a causation so that
it could be that kind of person is
already drawn to videogames and another
thing who I'm getting mad bring it you
want to break something that would
actually only prove their point no no so
video games are brought up often as
something like and when there's a
shooting oh he played Grand Theft Auto
yeah it cost this that's not really a
fair thing to say it's it's a it's a
popular scapegoat even our friend Diane
Feinstein kind of flipped on that after
I believe Sandy Hook she attempted to
get gun legislation in and it did not
work for various reasons that's a whole
another story but we're gonna stay on
topic she kind of changed ponies and
then at one point said oh well we have
to be aware of these violent video games
that are causing kids to do this
she changed ponies because she wanted
her name on the legislation against was
something with Sandy Hook that's she was
using it as politician so often do as a
scapegoat a crutch and it's frankly the
the facts don't support this yeah okay
so I want to get into some of the
specifics that Kim mentioned but let's
go to the scapegoat thing first because
to me it just seems like a giant
scapegoat this is just idiotic because I
grew up playing video games even Grand
Theft Auto I never even played the game
to accomplish anything all I would do
would be punch people and throw people
out of a car and drive over people and
you get to me you get that aggression
out and I never felt violent after
playing it I actually i maybe ate
mushrooms because mario did but that's a
whole other thing but really I mean do
you what what do you think you're the
good mushroom okay portobello mushrooms
MA okay yeah what do you think yeah you
know I mean I think it totally causation
is not necessarily correlation what did
you say with statistics is very very
very good what was your kind of man Jose
ssin causation and correlation are not
the same thing yes like it's not
something that caused something else
right it's just something a fact that's
there that also is has another phat
beside it right it's we're noting that
it's there we're not noting that
one be got the other yeah I mean I think
that if maybe if you're predisposed to
aggressive behavior you're interested in
theoretically in in violent video games
because it speaks to your aggressiveness
yeah I will say this though for work we
do a lot of video game reviews we do a
lot of playthroughs there were two games
that I kind of mainlined last year that
was BioShock Infinite and also Grand
Theft Auto 5 and it was like 15 hour
play days of this just non-stop and any
time you do anything for that amount of
time I mean it kind of screws up with
your brain like your body gets used to
like thinking in this pattern and you
you know would go outside and La Cienega
and think about how can I steal that car
and drive it into the Beverly Center
blow it up you know I mean you never
really do it right but it's like thought
actually did pop in your head in it
maybe but somewhat any more of a my
problem kind of thing you know and it's
really more about me as a person but I
wouldn't necessarily attribute it to
grand theft auto but if you do anything
I think if you watched if you if you
watch house of cards and you you
mainline that like so many people did I
was manipulating everybody you know like
they'll well now they know
sorry but but yeah I was just like you
know I was I was like the I'm actually
gonna be the president pretty soon
spoiler alert sorry well you know
interestingly in house of cards they did
it more in season one that he was
playing video games to get out his
aggression then in season two he got it
out in other ways I suppose especially
in the first episode but yeah so this is
just purely scapegoat stuff I mean why
don't people ever talk about the good
parts of video games the eye hand
coordination and the fact that you might
be exercising some other aggressions and
getting them out normally I'm sure
there's things such as the concept of
flow which is a psychological concept
I've talked about before it's something
where your your mind gets very you're
you're doing something that's very
challenging but also very rewarding to
you and it's this great reliever in your
psychological state you can get this
from playing Tetris but one thing I
wanted to talk about on the term back to
scapegoating yeah this is not the first
time this has ever happened of course
you can go call back to the comic code
authority of the 1950s and then it was
this government group censoring comics
and comments can only be approved by
them saying like oh they're they're
hurting our children they're making them
violent and delinquent with that
can roll blue jeans right so it's just
the next extension of all extension it
just keeps this will happen again with
whatever is after videogames or the next
version of videogames yeah so I'm
curious you guys that are in the the
gamer community what happened every time
there's a shooting and then some idiot
gets on TV and blames videogames without
knowing anything what goes on in the
gamer community actually like on the
message boards and on you know Xbox Live
and all that like our people are people
talking about it do they just ignore it
do they feel like they're being attacked
no I think unless you want to be
self-righteous about it and you want to
put it up for people to you know freaked
out about that for the most part it's
ignored because I don't think it's
really taken very seriously I mean video
gamers really are more interested in
that was kind of cool that's violence
again video game video gamers are more
interested in you know the imagination
of a video game of the world building of
the kind of alternate reality experience
that you get from doing something that's
an active intellectual experience a lot
of time seen a lot of these games are
super story heavy a lot of them are
really difficult from a coordination
standpoint and I think when you really
when you're really are a true gamer you
get that it's not about that but so far
you know it looks like to a lot of us I
think Washington just being upset yeah
kind of disagree I don't think it's
self-righteous to stand up for yourself
and say that I'm not this is not what
causes me to feel this way and I think
that's a problem actually that gamers
kind of keep to themselves and don't say
don't stand up more for themselves and
let these figures bear down on them and
blame them for things sure and then well
restate I mean it's self-righteous if
you're gonna be somebody who's posting
this story defending it saying like you
know you guys are the reason that all
these shootings are happening I mean
there's no that I don't think that it's
an active conversations being really had
and if you are gonna bring that up it's
like you're probably just trolling
because you're looking for somebody that
you know something to fight about and
you know what gamers don't have to agree
on everything so I think that is
actually okay
and I would be remiss if we did
something on video game violence and
school shootings and all that and we
didn't talk about the prescription drug
angle because that seems like a far
bigger problem than
the videogames to me is that does that
just seem pretty obvious to you guys
because that's what we always find out -
they don't always play video games but
90% of the time I'm willing to say
they're on some sort of prescription
drugs a stellar parenting I play as well
sometimes these games are rated mature
in their rated mature for a reason I'm
not saying that causes anything I am
saying maybe you should be aware of what
your child is playing and doing and
watching yeah yeah I mean I think that
obviously mental illness is a really big
issue we see it everywhere especially in
Los Angeles unfortunately and you know
until we sort of address that as the
cause of the problem they like the
issues up here right the issue the issue
is from within and it's not necessarily
the external fault you know I think that
maybe there's triggers there's things
that make people go crazy and go off the
deep end so to speak but but you know
it's it's until we turn the conversation
I feel like I'm a Hannity but if you
turn it until we turn the conversation
to sort of more about you know just like
what's going on and from a mental
standpoint then I think that you can
blame anything and you'll have just
exhaustive list of things to talk about
and for the record people Hannity causes
shootings not video